[Music]
ah
[music]
oh oh oh oh
oh oh
oh
oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
Please tell me about the building Oh
85 Come quickly, I guess there is no seal
[Music]
First of
all, there are people who can speak for the generation after announcing the common people, but
I'm happy with the reflection of Korean mullet, so I
solve it humorously
and turn the guns that common people can't talk about into the
sun.  It's a creepy job to unravel. It's
okay to
see
too what
oop pon uh mob uh
what
gospel uh hello I'm done in Korea
Intangible cultural asset No. 58
tightrope train trainee It is a friendship operation that is now registered as a student 9 uh uh
now I am protesting  In Seol General School, I majored in lotus leaf and was in my
sophomore year, and after 9
majors, there are
6 sports within the government,
and I am currently
majoring in
tightrope walking.  It's the day of Shilla Market
And since before
Oh
5 The sea is here in front of the
king So that heart When there
is a big event in that country, I was invited and
it was rubbing tightrope, so
I threw it in and stood there and walked
around for about three and a half hours Gold
[music]  ]
[Applause]
[Music]
Ah
ah ah,
once I live here, it is located in Mt. Gwanak, now it is
a wild flower
complex. Now, I used it as a tightrope learning center,
and
I said that it is a training ground.
[Music]
4 Old-born people are now in Gwacheon
[
Music
] When I was in high school, I
had a phone with one form, and now I am doing a form and now I am
in a
club.
There was no one
until then.  I think I'm doing it this way.
Above all else, if it's fun
, I
'm the one who doesn't know the passing of time. I don't know the passing of time and
I can do the same thing for 4 years
[Music
] Uh,
I used to criticize the shape class and
solve it humorously, but now  It's only a
social issue
or something to say good-
bye to.
Uh-ah-ah-
ah, I'm having a party with my brother-in-law, but I think it's probably
more like a child
role
.  I
want to let them keep
saying things like that again after
that.
The simple
punishment for suppressing anything is because let’s live
[music] The
last goes
[music] When
you ride the juu, the scene follows the scene,
the wind is very different.
Sometimes I get a
kick out, I gather wind, and the
thing that is necessary for a family is that I'm on stage now
, so I can't do it because the center of gravity [Music] falls during a performance and ends there
.
It's scary at the moment
5 When the
teacher is always talking now, tell me to focus, if I focus on it, I ca
n't hear
anything. It's really the same thing. Except for that one
glance, it's a mosaic
.
But
these days,
what should I say? When I’m in a relationship, the things I
think about a lot, I write a little
[music]
Write your own Oh Why
am I not there anymore?
Oh so in front  Well, it’s quilted in 2,
so it’s easy to say something like this, how can it be
too eccentric? There’s no code to enjoy it to the fullest. I
’m very impressed and, I have to
try, I’ve seen all the children’s writers
, so I dragged my back. The pain is a camera.
What am I going to do with this kind of person, I, you, ah, what am I going to do when
I think about it and
say I am going in front when it is declared, I just spread it and just go to the
ground
Honey 1 I took porridge and went there for over 40 years
.
Some of
us have a thigh, so we have to work
in the wilderness by keeping our morale more focused on our paychecks.
Taking advantage of history is
bad at times like this
[Applause]
I
didn't know it before, but now
I'm doing it
myself.  There is no one under the owner teacher
. Standing 2 Protected species 4
* 4 If
I quit, this is really what Hood
revives  Just like when I first learned , I
change step by step and look at each other, even if
I
step on it, I build up step by step one by one
that goes to the level 1 contact point.
we
on
[music]